Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, this week we're going
to be talking about the subject
of tissue engineering.
It's covered directly in
Chapter 14 but not in a lot of
detail.
I provided a couple of other
readings which are listed here
on this slide,
these are in the lecture notes.
If you go that folder there's
two papers, one from 1993 and
one from 2002.
I would read them in that
order, read the one from 1993
and then the one from 2002.
You'll see sort of how this
field, which I'm going to
describe today,
has evolved over the last 15
years or so.
Some of the challenges that
were talked about in this
article from 1993,
you'll see, are still present
today.
It's turned out to be more
difficult than biomedical
engineers thought to accomplish,
some of these things.
Some of the things have gone
faster, we've made more progress
than we thought we would in
1993.
If you read those two papers,
read the bit from Chapter 14
about tissue engineering,
and then Chapter 16 I've also
given you.
Chapter 16 is about
biomaterials and artificial
organs, but there might be some
things in there which are useful
to you in understanding this
subject as well.
Section will meet this Thursday
in the regular time and place.
What's the motivation for
tissue engineering?
This slide has a lot of numbers
on it and the particular numbers
are not important.
I've posted it in the notes for
the course so you can look at it
at your leisure,
but the main point here is that
there are many diseases that
drugs cannot treat effectively.
They're diseases that are
prevalent, they don't occur in
small numbers.
That's why all the numbers are
here so you can see how many
incidences there are of these
different--what is labeled on
this slide organ and tissue
deficiencies.
For example,
you know that burns of the skin
are quite common.
Some burns are not severe
enough that they need any other
treatment other than maybe some
antibiotic lotion and a dressing
while it heals.
Some burns are so severe,
or so extensive,
that they threaten the life of
the patient who has them.
If you lose enough of your
skin, you lose a lot of water
through that open area of skin.
You can become dehydrated to
the point where you can die of
dehydration.
Your skin is an important
barrier for keeping water inside
your body.
Of course, your skin is a
barrier for keeping other things
outside the body,
toxins, and in particular,
microorganisms,
viruses, and bacteria.
So, your risk of infection is
tremendous if you have large
burns over a significant part of
your body.
There's no way to--that we
currently know to speed up the
healing of skin fast enough that
patients that have severe skin
burns can survive that injury.
What's done is that you need
skin transplants;
you need preferably an
autograft of skin,
taking skin from one place in
your body and putting it in
another.
If you have severe burns over
much of your body,
then there's no skin to graft.
You might take an allograft,
an autograft is a graft from
you, from the individual to the
individual,
taking some of your tissue and
moving them to another location;
that's 'auto', self graft.
Allograft is from a similar
individual but not you,
somebody who might be matched
but not perfectly matched
immunologically to you and you
get a graft from them.
When you get a blood
transfusion from somebody that's
not you but there's some
matching that's gone on to make
sure that you're not going to be
incompatible with the blood,
that's an allograft.
Xenograft is a graft between
species, so that would be a
graft from another species to
human,
for example,
or between species,
so autograft,
allograft, xenograft,
good words to know for our
discussion on tissue
engineering.
You can imagine there's a
limited number of allografts,
that is skin transplants that
are available to treat burns.
So, not all the patients that
need them are able to get these
kinds of grafts and so life is
threatened in that situation.
Not only burns but there are
pressure sores,
what are commonly known as bed
sores for patients that have to
spend significant time in bed
because of an accident.
Let's say they've had a spinal
cord injury and they have to
spend a lot of time recovering
from that,
or they can't move anymore on
their own and they'll develop
sores which are very difficult
to heal.
Diabetics because they--because
Diabetes can affect the sensory
nerves in your extremities,
often get sores in their
extremities, particularly in
their feet or lower leg,
which don't heal very well;
partly because they can't feel
them as well anymore,
and so they become injured and
continue to get injured.
Partly because the process of
Diabetes slows down healing in
general, these--they get ulcers
or lesions on their skin that
don't heal.
Just this top category alone
lots of patients,
different indications,
not enough tissue to treat
these tissue deficiencies of the
skin;
if you went down this list you
would find many others as well.
Let me go down here,
we're going to talk about in
some detail the liver.
When you get liver disease
that's severe enough,
the only medical option right
now is a liver transplant.
We'll talk about why that's the
only option available for liver
disease that becomes very
severe,
that could result from some
metabolic disorder,
from cirrhosis,
or from liver cancer.
In that case,
a transplant is the only
option.
I'm sure you've all heard in
the news about cases where there
is a patient,
often a child,
who has some--a disease,
waiting for a transplant and
calls will go out to the
community.
This is a familiar story in our
society.
The reason for that is because
there are a significant number
of patients that are in this
category.
Not as many as in the case of
skin, but a significant number.
There is something like
tens of thousands of patients
that are eligible for liver
transplants and waiting for
them.
Why are they waiting?
Because there's not enough
donor organs to satisfy the need
of people that have transplants.
That's unlikely to change.
For a liver transplant donor to
become available,
somebody has to die with a
healthy liver,
they have to have consented to
have their organs used for
another person,
and they have to be matched
immunologically with the patient
who's going to receive the
donor.
Somehow, those two things have
to come together.
All of these things have to
work right in order for a liver
donor and a recipient to match.
They have to match not only
biologically,
but it all has to match in
terms of timing as well,
and that's a complicated
process.
Today, if you go and look
on this website,
we, 'we' meaning 'we as a
society',
have set up organizations and
procedures to try to help with
this matching process.
One of those is called The
Organ Procurement and
Transplantation Network.
They keep track of all of the
patients that are on lists
waiting for organ donations,
they keep track of all the
organs that are going to become
available and a matching process
occurs,
and computers are involved,
and all kinds of the resources
you would expect to be involved
in this thing.
If you look for any particular
kidney transplants,
there are currently as of
yesterday 75,000 individuals in
the U.S.
waiting for donor kidneys;
in the liver there are 16,000.
These are patients that today
need an organ donation,
their physicians have decided
that they're too sick to respond
to any other treatment and
they're just waiting for an
organ to appear.
I talked--in the very first
lecture you might remember,
I showed you this picture to
talk about--there's already very
high technology involved with
this medical effort.
Part of the technology are
things like this organ
procurement network.
This is run electronically on
the internet,
using all the high tech tools
of communication that we have in
order to connect physicians who
are trying to treat patients
with physicians who find that
there's a donor available,
and by other high tech
industries like the airlines who
can quickly move organs from one
place to another.
If the donor of the organ died
in California and the recipient
is here in New Haven,
then you've got to get the
organ as quickly as possible
from California to Connecticut.
That can be done now sometimes.
Another technology,
which is embedded in this,
is that some hours have to pass
between when the organ is
harvested and the organ can be
transplanted.
You need to be able to preserve
organs for that period,
however long that period is.
You'd like to be able to
preserve them for a long period
of time.
What if we could preserve donor
kidneys in the same way that we
preserve blood?
Blood--many of you have gone
when the Red Cross has come here
looking for blood donations.
They take your blood,
they store it in a special way
such that it can be used up to
three weeks past the point when
you donated.
That creates many opportunities
for your blood to be useful.
In the same way,
if you donated organs and there
were ways to preserve the organs
that would be--make them more
useful as well.
There's a whole technology
behind this that I wanted to at
least describe to you in words
and you could think about.
Biomedical engineers are
currently working around the
world on better ways to preserve
organs, but it's a difficult
problem.
It can be accomplished in blood
and certain kinds of blood
cells, can be partially
accomplished with some tissues
like skin,
cannot really be done with
livers or kidneys.
Not yet, but there's a great
need for that.
Why--I wanted to say a
little bit more about why you
have to take this extraordinary
measure of transplant to treat
diseases like liver failure.
When a liver becomes so
diseased that it cannot recover
its function on its own,
lots of things go wrong.
This chart is a table of some
of the functions which are
happening everyday in your
liver.
The liver is an important
endocrine organ,
we talked about the endocrine
system,
it makes hormones like IGF1,
it activates Vitamin D which
functions as a hormone,
is important for structure of
your bones, it produces the
hormones that are used in your
thyroid gland and many other
hormones.
If your liver starts to die you
start to lose the ability to
produce those hormones and you
can imagine,
then, that lots of things in
your endocrine system start to
go wrong.
The liver also produces many of
the clotting factors;
these are proteins that are
needed for clotting blood if you
have an injury.
If the liver starts to die
you're not making as many of
these, you can have a bleeding
disorder.
It makes plasma proteins like
albumin, which have many
functions in the body.
It makes bile acids,
and bile acids are very
important as an excretory organ
for getting rid of molecules
that the kidney is not able to
eliminate into urine.
I could go on down the list.
I put it here just to say that
when your kidney--when your
liver fails thousands of things
start to go wrong.
You could imagine treating any
one of these with drugs.
If the problem is activation of
Vitamin D you could take Vitamin
D, you could take pre-activated
Vitamin D.
If it was a thyroid hormone you
could take a thyroid hormone.
If it was any one of these
things, there might be a medical
solution for it.
But when it's this whole list
of things, because your whole
organ is failing,
you can't support that function
with drugs alone.
It's just too many things going
wrong at once.
Drug therapies are usually
used for treating something
where we understand what the
molecule is involved is and
where there's only one or two
molecules that are involved.
It's some metabolic disorder,
you're not making a particular
molecule that you need.
So, you take it in the form of
a pill, or you have an enzyme
that's not working properly and
so you take injections of that
enzyme.
In the case of cancer,
there's a single drug which can
eliminate the unwanted cells in
cancer.
These are areas where drug
therapy works.
Gene therapy,
which we talked about a little
bit, works in other kinds of
situations.
Where you're missing an element
of a cellular process;
like in cystic fibrosis for
example, your lungs and other
tissues are missing a membrane
protein that's important in
transport of chloride across
your lung epithelium.
Now, you can't just take that
protein because it won't get
inserted into the cells in the
right way.
We talked about membranes and
how proteins are inserted in
membranes.
You can't just give the patient
that membrane protein and have
it restored to the right
location in the cell.
Because it's only one thing
that's going wrong,
you can think about treating
this with gene therapy,
by giving those cells that are
missing the protein a gene that
allows them to produce that
protein on their own and to
correctly insert into the
membrane.
Gene therapy is possible to
think about in diseases like
cystic fibrosis and some
diseases of the liver and other
organs as well.
In general, they're diseases
that are caused by a single gene
defect.
When we're thinking about
liver failing lots of things are
going wrong, many genes
involved.
Gene therapy isn't really
thinkable in that situation
where the whole organ is
starting to fail.
Whole organ transplantation is
the only current solution,
a surgical solution for
problems like heart failure,
kidney failure,
liver failure,
where the whole organ is
starting to fail.
The motivation,
then, for tissue engineering is
to try to think about another
way to treat these diseases
where you would somehow
manufacture or create a tissue
in the laboratory that could
substitute for the transplanted
tissue from another patient.
The idea is to try to make
synthetic or semi-synthetic
tissues that could take over the
function of a failing liver,
a failing kidney,
a failing blood vessel,
a failing heart.
It is intended to treat these
diseases that are too complex to
think about complex in the
number of things that are going
wrong;
too complex to treat with any
of the other therapies we've
talked about over the course of
the--of our time here.
This is a field that was
really--has ancient roots,
and those ancient roots are
discussed in your book.
The idea of engineering tissues
was really only developed
relatively recently,
and first defined,
really, in the 1980s.
That first paper I gave you to
read by Langer &
Vacanti is really considered
one of the first,
most influential scientific
papers in this growing field.
Here's one definition of what
tissue engineering is.
I told you what the goals of it
are kind of in broad terms,
but it's the 'application of
principles and methods of
engineering and life sciences
toward fundamental understanding
of structure function
relationships in normal and
pathologic mammalian tissues'.
That's not the more interesting
part to me, the more interesting
part to me is,
'and the development of
biological substitutes to
restore, maintain,
or improve tissue function.'
Why is it only in the 1980s
that people started thinking
about this?
There's really two reasons and
one is an engineering reason,
a broad reason,
and the other is sort of life
science and biology reason.
We had come to the point in the
1980s where a lot of the biology
that we have talked about now
was fairly well known.
In particular,
the biology of cells in culture
of taking cells out of organs
and tissues,
maintaining them in culture,
getting them to do the things
we wanted to do in culture was
fairly well known by the 1980s,
it's a fairly mature technology.
One could think about using
cell culture techniques to
produce complicated structures.
The other is an engineering
advance and that is that we had
developed, by the 1980s,
enough understanding of
artificial biomaterials that we
could start to create materials
that had unique properties which
made them good candidates for
use in the kinds of applications
I'll talk about.
The innovations,
or the kind of foundations of
tissue engineering,
are our ability to culture
cells,
to do that reliably,
reproducibly,
to understand what cells are
going to do when we maintain
them outside the body,
and our ability to build
materials that are biocompatible
that can be implanted into
people and that can serve as
scaffolds for new tissue.
I'll say more about what that
means.
Just to try to put this in
more concrete terms,
here's two examples of how you
might artificially engineer a
tissue,
or two kinds of applications
that people might think about in
a heart that's failing.
I use this as an example
because we know a lot about the
cardiovascular system now and so
you'll understand both of these
examples.
We talked about the important
function of the blood vessels of
the heart, the coronary
arteries.
We also talked a little bit
about how these vessels can
become diseased in life,
particularly for patients in
the 6^(th) or 7^(th) decade of
their life.
This vessel might become
diseased through a process of
arthrosclerosis;
the lumen becomes narrowed such
that blood no longer flows.
The resistance gets too high
for blood to flow well,
so you'd like to replace this
artery.
The only thing that the
artery has to do is carry blood
from one place to the other,
so really all you need is a
tube.
People have tried for years to
use different kinds of tubes to
replace this section;
the operation is called a
cardiac-bypass.
A surgeon will go in,
he will remove this diseased
section of tissue,
or he'll just put a bypass
around it,
that is, a tube that goes from
this location and connects to
this location.
Like a bypass on the highway
it's a clear route that allows
you to get around a route that's
no longer passable.
Well, these vessels carry a
lot of blood.
They have to be very reliable
vessels because they need to
carry blood all the time because
your heart is constantly
working,
it needs a constant reliable
source of blood.
The best substitute for this is
a natural one.
So, one of the most successful
operations here is to take a
blood vessel from somewhere else
in the patient's body and use it
to create a bypass.
You'd like it to be an artery.
Bypasses can be made,
there's another artery that's
nearby called the internal
mammary artery that surgeons
could take.
You can take it from the tissue
sort of near the heart,
it doesn't really serve as
important a function,
and you can bypass it in here.
Now you have a new artery in
place to continue to flow blood.
That works,
but what if you have more than
one site of blockage?
What if you have a blockage
here, and a blockage here,
and a blockage over here,
and a blockage over here so you
need multiple bypasses?
You don't have enough arteries
in order to do that.
Then, the surgeon will go and
take the saphenous vein from
your leg.
It's a large vein in your leg
that returns blood that's flowed
down to your leg back up to the
vena cava.
There are enough other veins in
your leg that you can lose that
vein without any loss of
function in your leg.
They can now take the vein and
cut it up into segments,
and use that to bypass all
these segments of artery that
are clogged.
That works as well,
but veins aren't the same as
arteries, you remember that.
If you take a vein which has a
different anatomical structure
and put it in the position of an
artery that is exposed to the
high pressures that you know
already occur there,
sometimes that works.
Sometimes the vessel changes
and remodels and adapts so that
it functions,
and sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes those veins also
become diseased and they no
longer serve as an effective
bypass.
Then, what do you do?
If both of those options fail
you can try to use synthetic
materials.
Synthetic materials are used to
replace blood vessels in many
parts of the body.
If you have an aorta that has
an aneurism, a surgeon can put a
synthetic piece of,
basically Dacron,
a synthetic material.
It will serve as a functional
aorta and do a very nice job.
It turns out that we know from
experience, now,
that that only works if the
vessel is big enough,
because for big vessels all of
these kinds of synthetic
materials that we make.
While they might have the right
mechanical properties to serve
as an aorta, they're not
biological.
So, blood will clot when it
hits that unnatural surface.
It's okay if blood clots on
the surface of a big artery
because it's big enough that you
could have a lining of a clot
here along the inside,
and it would still be enough
diameter to flow.
If it's a small artery and it
clots blood doesn't pass through
any longer.
We know now that the limit of
what one can do with synthetic
materials is about half a
millimeter to a millimeter,
and that's the size of these
coronary arteries.
You can't use synthetic
materials there.
What we'd like to do is grow an
artery outside the body.
What if we could that by taking
the synthetic material and
growing on it a lining of
natural cells?
The synthetic material would
provide the mechanical
properties needed for it to
function as an artery.
If we could grow natural
arterial and endothelial cells
all over the surface of this,
the blood wouldn't know that
it's a synthetic material.
It would only see the cells
which are forming the natural
barrier, the natural wall of a
blood vessel,
so that's tissue
engineering--an example of
tissue engineering to create an
artificial artery to use in
bypass.
I'm going to talk more about
the details of where we are in
that process and what the
obstacles are next--on Thursday.
Let's say you didn't get
there in time and a particular
patient--they didn't have a
bypass in time so they have a
blockage.
They have a mild cardial
infarction or a heart attack
because the blood becomes
comprised to some area.
This area of the heart doesn't
get blood for some period of
time, and so this tissue in the
wall of the heart dies.
Now, in general if that happens
there's only a limited ability
of your heart tissue to heal
after you have a heart attack.
A scar is formed here and this
part of the heart doesn't
function in the same way that it
did before.
Remember how it functions,
is it has to transmit
electrical signals and it has to
contract in response to those
electrical signals.
It has to do that with a
regular frequency,
so it has to both conduct the
electrical signal and contract.
This damaged cardiac muscle
doesn't do that anymore.
Well, sometimes that's okay.
You might not need all of your
cardiac muscle to be functioning
in order to have a reasonable
efficient heartbeat,
but sometime the area of this
is so large that it compromises
the ability of your heart to
deliver the cardiac output you
need to stay alive.
What if you could make an
artificial cardiac muscle?
What if you could take some
kind of a material and grow
cardiac muscle cells on it?
Grow them in such a way that
they filled up this material and
they started to function like
heart,
that is, they functioned in the
right electrical way and they
functioned in the right
mechanical way.
Then, maybe a physician could
come in and just sew this patch
that you've created outside the
body into place on the tissue.
Maybe that patch would start to
function like that part of the
heart wall that didn't function.
Now, where would the cells come
from that you did that with if
we think about this particular
application,
we're going to create a patch
for repairing myocardial
defects.
Where would the cells come from?
What would be your first choice
of cells that you use for this?
Justin?Student: From
the heart.Professor Mark
Saltzman: From the heart.
From what heart?
Student: From the
patient's heart.Professor
Mark Saltzman: From the
patient's own heart.
What if you could take a small
biopsy of tissue from somewhere
else in the heart?
You could take a small sample
of those cells,
and you could take them outside
the body and grow them in
culture.
Well, this is where our ability
to culture cells comes in very
handy because we could take a
small sample,
isolate the cells we want,
propagate them in culture until
we had millions of those cells,
put them into the patch,
put the patch back into the
patient.
Now, the patient has an
autograft of cells,
but placed in the right
configuration so that they
function as a tissue.
What are the problems with that?
What's the problem with that?
Student: The entire
organ is
diseased.Professor Mark
Saltzman: If the disease was
too big you couldn't do that.
Why couldn't you do that?
Because you couldn't grow
enough cells,
you think,
or--Student: Because
[inaudible]
doesn't use tissue
[inaudible].Professor
Mark Saltzman: Yeah.
You might--there might be some
practical limits to it but
you're getting close to what the
real problem with that would be.
Think about the timing of it.
How long would it take you to
take this biopsy and grow the
cells and make a new
artificial--probably would take
weeks to do.
Could the patient survive those
weeks while you're making the
tissue engineered solution?
Maybe, maybe not,
it would depend on how
extensive the failure of the
heart was, as Justin described.
What would be another
solution to that?
Well, let's not take cells from
the patient but let's create a
bank of heart cells.
That might be possible,
but you have to be able to
preserve heart cells.
You have to have a bank of
cells with all the right
immunological markers labeled,
you have to have them in enough
quantity that they would be
available rapidly.
There's problems with that but
maybe you could do it that way.
Maybe you could use stem cells.
We talked about stem cells
before and some of their
capabilities,
but one of the real advantages
of what people think of as using
stem cells to treat diseases in
adults is just exactly what
we're talking about here.
Being able to create an
environment or an engineering
solution in which stem cells
could be used to create
functional tissue.
In this case you'd want stem
cells that could very quickly
become cardiac muscle cells that
could be differentiated in the
cardiac muscle cells.
Ideally, you'd want stem cells
from the same person,
you'd like to isolate them from
the same person somehow,
or from a donor that was
matched.
You're starting to see both the
opportunity, I hope,
and the problems that have to
be solved in creating these new
solutions.
I list on this slide a few
of the characteristics of tissue
engineering that we're going to
talk about,
not in quite this organized a
way, but I hope that by the end
of the week you'll be able to
look back at this list and say,
'Oh, I understand what that
characteristic means in terms of
what we're trying to accomplish
in tissue engineering.'
The first is what I've been
talking about up to this point.
The tissue engineering really
represents kind of a modern or
contemporary logical extension
of conventional medical and
surgical practices.
If we're going to make an
engineered tissue,
in many cases,
we're going to give them to a
surgeon and they're going to do
what they know how to do,
which is replace an organ or a
tissue.
You're just giving another
resource to surgeons to do what
they know how to do already.
We're using it to extend
medical practices to diseases
that can't be treated by drugs
or gene therapy or other kinds
of medicine.
What I want to talk about
for most of the rest of the time
today is this second bullet
here,
that tissue engineering
involves control or regulation
of normal healing processes.
That if we want to understand
and use tissue engineering we
need to know something about how
the body heals itself and take
advantage of those natural
mechanisms of tissue
regeneration.
We'll talk over the course of
the next two lectures about
tissue engineering as an attempt
to replace the cellular
component of diseased tissues.
Whereas in drug therapy we're
thinking about the molecular
component, now we're replacing
cells,
that it uses cellular processes
sometimes to control drug
delivery.
We'll talk about how you could
use tissue engineering as a drug
delivery system,
and that tissue engineering
produces new models for the
study of human physiology.
I won't say anything more
about that this week,
so let me just say that now,
that what if you could produce
heart tissue like this for
transplantation?
Another use for it would be if
I can make this tissue outside
the body that behaves like the
human heart,
I can use it to study how the
human heart works outside the
body in a much more reliable
way,
or a much more sophisticated
way than I could with ordinary
cell cultures.
Because now you not only have
the cells of the heart but you
have the cells of the heart
arranged in the right kind of
configuration,
so I could understand--I could
use it to understand how the
heart develops.
I could expose it to different
drugs and ask,
'What are the toxicities of
these drugs to the normal
heart?'
without doing it in patients,
and with doing it in a system
where I have a lot of control
and a lot of ability to look
inside and see what's happening.
Let me go back to this
point now, tissue engineering
involves control or regulation
of the normal healing process.
We're all familiar with at
least some aspects of healing
because you've all had a cut in
the skin that has maybe caused
you some distress in the short
term.
Maybe it was a cut that was
deep enough, and this shows you
the structure of the skin.
Here's the outer layer of the
skin here that forms this sort
of thick barrier layer,
the epidermis that things can't
penetrate;
water can't penetrate easily.
You put water on top of your
skin, it beads up there,
it doesn't get absorbed.
Likewise, water inside doesn't
come out and that's why you
don't get dehydrated.
Microorganisms can't go through
because of this barrier.
Underneath is a more
connective tissue layer called
the dermis and inside this
dermis there's cells that are
producing an extracellular
matrix of collagen,
largely.
We talked about extracellular
matrixes several weeks ago.
Within that collagenous matrix
there are blood vessels,
arteries red here,
veins blue.
Those blood vessels bring blood
to the skin to provide oxygen,
and to get rid of carbon
dioxide in these cells in your
living skin.
You get a cut in this tissue
and what happens if it's a deep
enough cut you bleed.
You got to do something to stop
the bleeding.
You've had this and so you put
some pressure on and you wait
for clotting to occur,
but you've disrupted these
vessels.
They have clotted so that a
clot has formed inside these
vessels so that the bleeding
stops.
Usually a clot forms at the
surface.
If you look at this after
you've got the bleeding stopped
you have a red looking area.
It looks different from your
skin, that's the beginning of
the healing process,
is that your body has
coagulated blood at that site to
replace the tissue that's been
lost.
You'll have a red spot there
that turns into a reddish
looking scab.
That's your body responding to
stop the immediate insult,
the bleeding,
and to fill up the space of
this tissue that's been damaged.
Cut's too big,
this can't happen,
you can't just put pressure on
it and stop it,
and so what do you do?
You go to the emergency room,
you get some stitches.
They bring the sides of that
wound back together with
stitches, they hold it closed.
The same thing happens but in
the smaller space now,
because they've just brought
the tissue together so that your
body could produce this
provisional tissue.
The provisional tissue at the
beginning is just a blood clot.
After that point many
things start happening within
the skin, and a complex process
of cells sending out signals and
cells responding to signals in a
coordinated and regulated way
occurs.
What this diagram shows is some
little fingers of tissue
entering into this coagulated
provisional matrix that was
formed by the blood clot.
These cells are initially cells
that are called fibroblasts
which live in the dermis.
Normally, they're just sitting
there sort of in a quiescent
state, not reproducing very
rapidly,
making collagen,
providing matrix to keep up
sort of the normal structure of
your skin.
When there's an injury,
they get turned on and they
migrate into the wound.
They migrate into this
provisional matrix and they
start changing it.
They start digesting the clot
and they start making new
extracellular matrix of
collagen.
They do that so that there can
be a pathway for these blood
vessels to regrow.
The blood vessels need to
regrow, renourish the skin so
that you can start to get the
normal composition back,
the normal cellular components,
and you'll see these blood
vessels starting to form sprouts
that enter into this provisional
matrix.
Now, you've watched the
process of a scar healing on
your own body and you've seen
the stages that it goes through.
It will go from the red
appearance to a duller red,
and eventually become a white,
or it doesn't look red at all.
After some period of time you
won't even see where the cut was
at all.
The end process of these
fibroblasts coming in,
replacing, remodeling the
matrix of blood vessels
regrowing back in,
establishing new cells from the
epidermis start to grow in over
this matrix in the end.
First they'll grow over the top
and so you might see a little
bump here.
Eventually the whole tissue
through this elegant
self-regulated process heals
itself so you can't see where
the cut was,
we've all had that experience.
Probably we've also had the
experience when we got a worse
cut and it didn't end up looking
right.
You might still have a scar
from some cut that you got on
your hand or your arm where it
was too severe.
Now, what happened there?
The same process of remodeling
happened but it happened in a
more aggressive or more vigorous
way because the signals that
control this were large.
It was a large wound,
big problem,
lots of cells got activated,
they made a lot of collagen,
they remodeled this provisional
matrix very aggressively.
Why?
So, that you could heal,
and so that you wouldn't have a
wound here that was open to
infections or loss of blood or
loss of water.
Your body knows how to
respond to very severe injuries,
more severe than we usually
encounter in our lives.
The result is you'll get a scar
form that because the response
was too aggressive.
Our ancestors,
who lived much more dangerous
lives than we did,
who might get attacked by a
lion or a bear,
needed to have a very
aggressive healing response so
they didn't die if they got
attacked under some
circumstances.
We don't get attacked by lions
or bears so often anymore and so
we don't necessarily need that
aggressive healing response.
We might like a gentler healing
response that leads to a better
functional--that doesn't have a
scar, for example.
How can you control healing
in that case?
Well, one of the ideas of
tissue engineering is to provide
materials that would guide,
or regulate,
or change that natural response
of healing.
You have a wound and the wound
is going to heal on its own in
some way.
You would like it to heal in
way that you control so that the
outcome is more to your liking.
Now, maybe the outcome is that
it heals much faster,
maybe the outcome is that it
heals without a scar;
heals and new kinds of cells are
woven into the tissue in place
of the ones that were there
formerly.
Maybe this wound was created by
a surgeon who removed a cancer
here, and you're trying to
replace the cancer cells with
normal cells.
What are the options in
terms of doing this?
Well, one is that you could put
a material in here and the
material goes into the wound.
That material has some
function, and maybe that it
serves as a better provisional
matrix then the clot would have.
'Better' means what?
Maybe it regulates how cells
grow in or how cells attach,
or how cells synthesize
collagen after they enter.
Maybe you could design a
material that changes the
healing response locally.
That's one way that you might
engineer a tissue.
Now, here I haven't put any
cell cultures in,
I've just put in a fancy
material that I designed.
We'll talk about what those
might be a little bit later.
Maybe you don't need
material at all,
but maybe you could replace
this with cells.
Maybe I could just take cells,
maybe recovered or harvested
from some other place in the
patient.
Maybe these are skin cells that
I got from a normal location and
I put them back into a wound in
order to speed up the process of
healing at that site.
Maybe they're stem cells that
came from somewhere,
or maybe they're just cells.
Often times the best
combination seems to be to put
cells in together with some
material.
Here, the material might
function in a couple of
different ways.
It might function in this way
we talked about here,
by giving signals to the normal
tissue to regulate the healing
response that's going to occur
anyhow.
That material might contain
cells that you have derived
somehow, that you want to hold
in that site;
that you want to hold locally
and provide an environment where
they can grow and take over the
function of the tissue.
These are some sort
schematic ways to think about
how one might use tissue
engineering to control the
normal healing process.
I've shown this,
I've given you examples of this
that--where I motivated it with
thinking about the skin,
but this doesn't have to be the
skin.
This could be your liver.
Maybe I put a material into
your liver that allows it to
regenerate.
Maybe I put liver cells derived
from some other source back into
the liver, and they take over
the function of the liver.
Maybe I put materials on cells
and create a new liver tissue.
So, you could extend this idea
to almost any tissue or organ.
Here's an example of that,
where just the material is used
to guide the healing process.
I think this is conceptually a
very simple idea and one that
works to some extent.
This is a nerve.
'Proximal' means closer to the
brain, so maybe this is a nerve
in your leg and it's got severed
by some kind of injury or it got
crushed and somehow the nerve is
damaged in this region here.
This nerve is sending sensory
signals from the distal part,
back up the nerve into the
brain;
it's sending motor signals down
from the brain to the more
distal regions.
If this tissue--if this nerve
gets damaged by trauma somehow,
then you're not going to get
sensory signals sent through it,
you're not going to get motor
signals.
So, you can't feel,
you can't move and all of the
tissue that's distal or
downstream of that site.
How do--how would you repair
that?
Well, it turns out that
surgeons know that if it's a
small region and they go back in
and they take the damaged ends
of the nerves and they put them
back together,
you will recover much of the
function of that nerve.
Maybe not 100%,
but if they do it quickly and
they do it well that these cells
will regrow the connections that
are lost in this section of
trauma.
You will, over a period time,
begin to feel in that tissue
again and you'll be able to
move.
If the damage is too big,
you can't physically bring them
back together.
Your leg is a fixed link and if
the area of damage is too big
you can't bring these tissues
back together.
They found that you can use an
autograft, that is take a nerve
from somewhere else.
If I cut the nerve out of
another spot and then put it in
this region in between the two
ends, the nerves will regrow
again.
Problem with that is you don't
have a lot of nerves that you're
not using.
So, in order to repair this
nerve you had to sacrifice a
nerve somewhere else.
Maybe you could do that
same thing with a material,
so what would the material look
like?
The material might look like
this, and this is just a
cylindrical cuff and it's a
complete cylinder.
It's shown as a cutout here
just so that you can see inside,
but it's a complete cylinder
that's hollow and you put one
end of the nerve into one end,
and one end of the nerve into
the other.
Now, you've placed these
nerves, not in physical contact,
but you've created a
compartment through which they
can communicate.
You don't have this end of the
nerve dangling out in space and
this end of the nerve dangling
out in space.
Remember it's not going to be a
nice picture like this where the
nerve is existing on its own,
but there's muscles and blood
vessels and other kinds of
things around in this area.
By putting a channel with a
nerve in both ends you've
isolated the area of the nerve
you want to regenerate from all
the rest of the tissue.
Does that make sense?
You hope that you get some
regrowth through here.
What scientists have found
is that if you do this you will
get some regrowth.
You don't get complete regrowth
of a thick nerve,
but you get a thin nerve with
less fibers,
less nerve tissue,
less function but you get some
recovery.
So it works,
and we've known for about 20
years or so that it works but it
doesn't work well enough,
so how could I make it better.
Well, one way you could make it
better is by changing the
material.
Maybe the properties of the
material weren't right,
maybe the cuff on the outside
is too impermeable and you'd
like to have molecules
exchanging in some way.
Maybe it's not permeable enough
and so you need to regulate it
that way.
Maybe you don't want a nerve
cuff that's filled with just air
or just water,
but maybe you'd like a nerve
conduit that's filled with a
material that promotes the
growth and reconnection of these
fibers.
Maybe you'd like some kind of a
gel in there that nerves could
regenerate through.
So, the obvious place to go
for that is to use the kinds of
materials that the body uses for
repairing tissues.
Fill up this channel not just
with water or saline,
or some kind of a solution,
but fill it up with an
extracellular matrix,
like the kind of extracellular
matrix we talked about weeks
ago,
that all of your tissues have.
A supporting gel like
structure, formed from proteins
and carbohydrates that are
secreted by cells,
and through which cells
normally grow and live.
Taking natural proteins like
collagen, forming gels out of
them and putting these gels
inside the material increases
the number of fibers that grow
across a gap like that.
This is just an example
of--a simple example,
no cells involved here of a
material that's designed in
order to enhance the healing of
a wound and how one might
engineer properties of that
material to make it better at
supporting the healing function.
That's what I wanted to say
about tissue engineering
involves control or regulation
of the normal healing process.
I want you to keep that in mind
as we go through the examples
that we'll talk about in
Thursday's lecture.
I'm going to stop there.
Questions?
See you on Thursday.